hey everybody Black Panthers here boy
was it fun and as we finish our you know
third and fourth viewings of it our
sights begin to turn to the next big
event on the marvel cinematic calendar
guys Avengers infinity war how exactly
did Black Panther set the table for this
epic showdown well we got all the
updates that this movie gave us but
first welcome to new rockstars news our
deep dive into all the biggest stories
this week so we're also gonna talk about
that recently released Thor Ragnarok
blu-ray and the movies deleted scenes
and the upcoming x-force Deadpool
spin-off movie and more I'm Erik Vasa
joining me at the table are my friends
wood Garrett Lord Garrett's over here
same basher with conviction Sam and what
new things we learned about it from
watching Black Panther while director
Ryan Coogler was it to focus on setting
up other elements of the MCU in the
future yeah probably for the best if you
watch Black Panther closely and paid as
close attention as we did to the footage
from the upcoming Avengers infinity war
trailers and statements by the cast and
crew we started to get a clearer picture
of what may go down when Thanos takes on
the Avengers this may of course spoiler
warning for black panther coming up and
Avengers infinity war in case any of
these predictions end up being right at
all but you know you're okay now beyond
the obvious detail of Bucky Barnes
Winter Soldier showing up at the
post-credits scene establishing him in
Wakanda to fight alongside them when
Fanus arrives we know he won't be the
only former rival to black method a join
two challahs team remember the five of
various rival tribes of Wakanda and
black panther we saw two chala fighting
against in Baku the mountain tribe
and later siding with him briefly
against the border tribe during kill
mongers brief rule and the infinity war
trailers looking closely you could see
in Baku as well as the blue rope so the
border tribes Duke would do relationship
problems yes I guess yeah I mean
possible Oscar winner Daniel Kuya at
that point we'll see we want a BAFTA oh
well we'll see it looks like yeah all
these tribes are on the same side now
joining Black Panther and the
Dermalogica against the invading
outriders of Thanos so we're in for a
unification of tribes of Wakanda against
a common enemy what do you guys think
you probably covered this because you
break things down but in the we're gonna
go into how the end credits of setting
us up right yeah well we can talk about
that now in this instance Bucky Barnes
and his point and his purpose ah
do you notice when the kids were going
into the tent and they called him white
wolf yeah so this is like the little
nugget from a different part of the
comics where the white wolf was is it to
Chaka who is to Charlie's father hired
this foreign hunter who was called the
white wolf to look after the Black
Panther Army or the war dogs and all
that and basically acted as like the
Bucky Barnes of the group which is the
one who you know gets the orders takes
the team execute the order comes back so
the works for yeah it works for the king
so the fact that he's called white wolf
and that's what the white wolf in the
comics did I think that we're gonna see
more of Bucky Barnes kind of staying
Wakanda get the technology get his arm
put back on properly learn about all all
the things happening and then probably
work with Sheree and Lupita Nyong'o
Nakia Nakia and yeah build up his team
and work for Wakanda is like a head of
security you should hang out there I
liked especially that last scene of him
coming out of a like a hut because it's
more like it's not tech base it's not
him integrating with like a city it's
him going like getting roots back to
Nate
kind of getting a detox a little bit
about being safe yeah still great yeah
and so like I'd like him to like kind of
get grounded and just kind of hang out
around here if he's allowed another
trying to open their doors but maybe
he's a murderer he's wanted globally so
maybe like like way you can stay just
outside he could stay over here that's
fine but no he would what I would like
is if they begin a new army or you saw
in the trailer
make it the sand tech make it like make
it like you're like the composition of
it I think that'd be like a
shape-shifting kind of arm that'd be
real fun yeah I you know Dana Kuya
called
Black Panther Marvel's Game of Thrones
and like we talked about this in the
break down how although like political
drama of like the royal family did feel
like those could be like Starks versus
Baratheon sumo not and I think if we
were continuing to extend that metaphor
it'd be interesting to see how of
interest infinity war we'll see all
these warring units coming together with
like Bucky beam maybe like the Hound
type you know a lone wolf type figure or
lone white wolf in this case having to
like join forces with the the Jon Snow
of this world and all these other forces
it's kind of fun to see the team gather
together with their different interests
speed in a video where you compare that
like Game of Thrones tomorrow stuff yeah
we'll see I think it'll be a real fun
thing to see I mean we would be nice if
we could have like another movie to see
these people come together but maybe
that's what the first act of this
infinity war will be it's more fun to
actually watch The Avengers trailer now
okay so then you're like oh I actually
don't I mean yeah caps back but it's
like a coy haze there and you seem Baku
I'm like yeah actually I want to see
them and I want to that there's a meme
going around where it's like fan OHS is
like introducing himself and you just
hear in Baku though he's like
yeah now that we yeah we get a sense of
the full toy box that we get to play
with now it'll be fun to rewatch all the
Avengers infinity war trailers now that
we really get a full sense of everything
well next up there's another character
Cherie - Charles younger sister played
by Leticia right she's so great for many
she stole the movie with her charm
uncanny engineering skills and general
genius now many have begun to actually
push for a friendship maybe something
more between Cherie and Peter Parker who
honestly seems like a perfect match for
her at least I'm intellectual level when
it comes to like tinkering with tech and
their their senses of humor I don't know
if the ages are really lined up there
I'm not really sure how old
Cherie is but she has sudden interviews
that she would be she would love for her
character to be matched up with
spider-man I think that's more from like
a fan perspective than like any kind of
shipping perspective but what do you
guys think do you want to see a Cherie
spider-man team-up and infinity war be
friends you get tech from Ironman get
some tech from Surry be cool get some of
those in your suit that'd be awesome
yeah I'm actually thinking Cherie is
going to spend a lot of up close and
personal time with Bucky Barnes to undo
the Hydra implant and to kind of turn
him from being a weapon back to a person
and I think that bonding experience is
maybe going to take yeah and the fact
that you know yeah the tech side of
things mixing in with the humanity side
of things yeah what are you what you are
Guardians a galaxy she teams up with
them and she gets to play with all the
space tech and she gets to make a like a
giant rocket or she gets to play around
with GRU anything more like how rocket
likes to build like little like bombs
and whatnot and then you have her like
also take caring with that as well Aeryn
rocket being BFFs right I would love if
like between infinity War part 1 & 2
we're able to see like various short
films like the way that they did is
Marvel one-shots like it'd be really
great to see just like one off side
adventure with with Groot and Cherie
just for like five minutes I would love
it do you know my favorite thing about
Cherie is that she almost makes tiny
stock redundant because like her
technology is more powerful there was
that great moment in Black Panther where
Martin Freeman's character gets shot in
the spine and he's better after a day
that kind of technology just like and
actually spoke to Leticia right
interviewed her and my favorite analogy
that I used was like Sheree
compared with Tony Stark is like
remember met him
black and you had Tommy Lee Jones agent
Kay you kind of did everything and then
Will Smith came in you guys I make this
look good difference between you and any
stock I got a real watch I got a real
watch that movie I forgot how good man
black is my first ever date movie yeah
also we know another character who kind
of messed up their spine real bad so I
feel like she could maybe help out a
little bit right yeah birdie could use
some help I mean I know he's got like
it'd be kind of cool to have someone who
has like a disability in the movie yeah
yeah that's interesting but also it's
like if you have a way of fixing that
like with magic needs that for a
necklace it's also fashion that's also a
communicator which is also a phone but
it's also like medicine it's like what
do everything professors like yeah
there's a ton of characters that I would
just love to see teamed up i maybe it
might be a little too soon for infinity
War part 1 but like there's a whole
other phase for coming up after this
that you know once that presumably they
they move on from the old guard of like
Tony Stark Iron Man it could be fun to
see like Peter Parker and and ensure
East swap notes and see like no argue
with each other on who has a more
superior tech well next there's the
question of the final Infinity stone
right like many of us thought the soul
stone
the last remaining Infinity stone would
be revealed by the MCU and it would show
up in black panther of course didn't
happen why would it I know it was a soul
there was souls and they were stones new
rocks credits roll yeah
now many of you have seen the other
video on the channel where I actually
dig into some of the theories I'm aware
that and final things don't could be but
one of the theories I brought up was
that the soul stone is actually hiding
in plain sight in black panther the
massive mountain of vibranium from the
crashed meteorite now it does give the
world Condon's power to communicate with
the souls of the dead and we do know
from the infinity war trailers that they
a Knossos army is attacking what Ghana
clearly wants something from their brain
it's useful in other way an infinity
stone to be useful of course but one of
the theories is that the whole mound
that whole mountain could be the
Infinity stone itself or it could be
embedded deep within that mountain and
while koogler
the director denied this the MCU has
been known to go back and retroactively
lis make other MacGuffins Infinity
stones as well in the past like the
Loki's scepter later contain the mine
stone and I'm a Komodo did end up also
containing the time stone and they had
different meanings before they were
revealed to be Infinity stones but what
do you guys think do you think the low
soul stone is in Wakanda do you think
because it explains like you know
technology why this particular story or
like substance is that much more
advanced and does that much more on this
technology like it is so advanced and is
it just like a magical substance are we
saying that this is like some sort of
what's the venom yeah we saying it's a
second um but one of those things all
we're gonna give it absolute purpose I
like your theory yeah it's possible I
think that the downside of it which we
pointed out before it's like oh great
another infinity stone on earth and all
the cosmos people are saying it might be
on the thumb right so you have mine
stone the yellow one the hope well
actually that's in the comic right now
that's a that's an element they're doing
the power stone like the purple one from
guardians the galaxy is the size of a
planet basically and a star revolves
around it that's how powerful it is so
they change that up and I feel like they
came up with that because they read
there something down the hall they're
like oh that's a really good idea we can
make a comment before we make a movie
and like they could do that but I think
maybe it's in the vibranium because it
has so much power and like there's ways
of turning it on and off sorry
then maybe it's in there but also it
could just be the MacGuffin that goes
from in
part one and two like you can't maybe
you can't have the whole thing put
together which could work but also
rewatching Avengers I did a breakdown of
it and it was one of the coolest things
that scene you guys probably remember
it's when all the Avengers are turning
on each other before Hulk Hulk's out on
the Helicarrier and it gets attacked oh
yeah it ends the shot on the scepter
like focusing on it and it shows
everything upside down because it was
done on purpose as a way because Joss
Whedon didn't like say anything when he
basically made it like besides everyone
in it Marvel Studios that that was
already set up to be the mind stone oh
very nice right off the bat like that
was supposed to be the thing because
once everyone goes at each other's
throats when they're near it when
they're away from it they don't go near
each other's throats that's very it's
really cool and it only happens like it
makes people act out a character to like
count breaks in somewhere to go find
evidence it's like why would he do that
it's because he's not thinking straight
that he's kind of going crazy and they
all like go to each other's throats it's
a really great scene if you watch it
yeah even banner who's like the main
goal of that scene he ends up taking
players like dr. banner put down the
scepter he is because Loki like
basically programmed that thing to make
him want to do that that's very cool
like Hulk out it's a really great scene
really smart
anyways I think it's definitely I think
I like all these theories I think it
there needs to be like an in-between
like to get into the next movie and it
would be kind of fun to have like the
Infinity Gauntlet put together at the
end of this movie but if we need
something to connect it like Captain
Marvel has it somewhere like or
something like sure yeah I think we
couldn't give the benefit of the doubt
to like [ __ ] in the whole Marvel team
like they're thinking every possible
possibility out yeah and they got a
master plan they've been pretty good
about rolling out it could be like you
know how they split the final Harry
Potter film and a part one in part two
and you didn't really have and yeah
they're doing it it's not just for
creative reasons it's probably for money
but they didn't have Voldemort acquiring
the Elder Wand
until the final shot of part 1 and we
could have something similar happen here
at OU the death weapon won't be acquired
until the final frame or the post-credit
okay so upset if the phrase no glove no
love is not at least three times at
least a poster on the background and
like someone just whispers it
I wouldn't be interested to see like if
not an infinity stone why is Santos
attacking what kind it could be
something like you know an independence
day where they attack like the most
powerful cities like arguably the city
in Wakanda is the most technologically
advanced city on earth so maybe that's
just why he starts there
we'll see let us know your thoughts and
what you're most excited about now
looking forward to infinity war now that
you've seen black panther and do you see
any other connections or any other
possible outcomes of what might is what
is now possible in this world now that
we know everything from Black Panther
Bucky what is that I'm trying to think
of the ship name that's actually more
important can you do that and they come
I'd prefer that yeah yeah well let's
move on to this week's trivia question
we're sticking with a black panther here
okay so um in a black panther according
to the coordinates visible in his
father's diary and kill mongers
flashback what real-world African
country is the nation of Wakanda
contained within is my Achilles heel I'm
not even gonna tell you how old I was
before I looked at a map and realized
that Russia and China touches a lot of
things in Australia and we are one
island so far removed from everywhere
else it's kind of like oh that's all
cool up there and then there's us so I
did a I did a I did a assignment when I
was in grade five on this country which
is not where it is but it's the only one
I really know with confidence but grade
five is like the equivalent of like
grade 12 in the US right like you guys
have a superior education I assume over
there clearly because I know
everything about geography um but yeah
it's it's a real country it what Conda
does not exist on the African continent
in real life it's a it's a fictional
country do you know there is a Wakanda
and like Wisconsin or Illinois yeah it's
like and they like to stop asking for
vibranium we don't know what vibranium
make like a little like theme-park maybe
why not yeah cash in on that it it's
kind of like if you want to Breaking Bad
the it takes place in albuquerque
albuquerque right and the house that
they shoot and people go visit it's like
a tourist spot and if you were to bring
a bad you know Walt throws the pizza
frisbees it up on the roof and now
people go there and they try to throw
this piece on this poor old lady's roof
and then the showrunner breaking had to
be like please stop going to eat
suspended swimming through it's terrible
to clean up it's impossible to get it
there and do it often they don't realize
it's up there for days stop doing yeah
because you would like it's just a pitch
they'd be like Oh barely land on it yeah
well later we'll reveal the answer to
this trivia question
the coast is decided by our judges we'll
get to do our sign off goodbyes and
whatever character they want to do and
later go and the loser will have to
cleverly riff on her in other news
headlines but let's move on to our next
topic because it's a Newark surgeon
who's we cover all the news you need to
know guys thor ragnarok released some
deleted scenes this week the blu-ray for
Thor Wagner came out and a bunch of
bonus goodies came along with it
including yeah all the deleted seats
that show the interesting alternate
angles of directors the director almost
went with in this movie so let's do a
rundown of all these scenes and discuss
how they would have changed this film
okay the first change involves the
sequence with Thor and dr. strange and
Odin's death now originally strange was
just gonna screw around a lot more with
or like making a key pop out of his
mouth that would free Loki who rather
than just like falling through another
dimension for thirty minutes
strange trapped him inside a port-a-john
so that key is how how Thor coulda got
him out but also straight shows Thor a
map of New York City pointing out the
location of his father who in this
version was disguised as a homeless man
you may have seen some set photos before
the reshoot app and they look like a
glass yeah yeah but then Odin's death
and this
whole confrontation of hello was going
to happen in New York alley as we saw
actually in the initial trailer for the
movie before this was changed
director Taika Waititi moved all of this
to Norway because you know he wanted a
not-it's death to have more meaning and
more emotion behind it Norway of course
is the birthplace of North mythology
North's mythology which is the origin of
all these characters so that involved
rewriting and reshooting reconfiguring
all of Odin's death and Hellas arrival
on this cliffside field in Norway and
reconfiguring the part of dr. Strange's
scene that you know moved into that if
you watched that scene by the way in 3d
you can definitely tell they shot that
last minute because not all the scenes
cuz it's grass and when you move forward
in that it looks like here's a panel
here's a panel here's a panel it's not
great
blu-ray great you'll love it by that but
I'd be curious to see I mean you can see
the Doctor Strange part of in the
deleted scenes they don't show the
actual Odin death scene as what how it
went down that alley I think it probably
seemed really really like tone-deaf for
dirty homeless person who yeah
yeah it seemed a little maybe
disrespectful as a character but uh but
it's I like the way they reshot it
seemed pretty sentimental but let's move
on to another one next there was
originally going to be a lot more
footage of the crews escape from us a
car and the return to Asgard there's
gonna be a lot more from the chases
people like arguing aboard the ship also
in the final cut the trip through the
temples anus wormhole it happens
relatively quickly it's almost like
lights up lights lights and lights up
but a deleted scene shows Thor and
banner hanging out on the ship they
there is is the Grandmaster a sex tape
hologram where he's interacting with
some alien creature but they have arms
and these like blue socks that
originally gonna be swapped out later
for like tentacles I assume and he's
like making out with him it's pretty
awesome meanwhile banner and Thor are
discussing like the pressure doors
feeling with this like family dynamics
and Banner actually compares them to
Dumbo you know like Dumbo had the magic
feather but he never needed it was
inside them all along same with like
Thor's hammer he doesn't need it to be
powerful he's not the god of hammers
it's a really good scene yeah it's
pretty great and live then of course it
ends with banner suddenly realized he's
not eating like ramen noodles there he's
gross now there's some kind of xenomorph
looking tentacle thing that he's eating
and he swats away and Valkyrie just
comes in and like munches on it she's a
badass she's awesome
well I'm sorry she's a I can't see it
she's a shirt there's also a few other
scenes I would describe as you know kind
of Anton oh but they're super fun a
chase between Hulk and Thor through the
streets it's a car it's a pretty funny
riffing by the Grand Master topaz over
like hand gestures and whether somewhere
Universal what they mean really funny if
an entire boy Tate II would have done it
because he's got a wicked sense of humor
would've been really cool Thor and Hulk
pretended to have a race and who would
run faster like a Superman yeah before a
test more than just the test of strength
they hadn't battle yeah there was a
brief moment where scourge spots
Heimdall escaping with the Asgardian
citizens and kind of let some escape it
was something that would probably be
foreshadowing his later moment of
redemption on the bridge but I think one
of my drawbacks with the movie was that
the whole Heimdall subplot seemed a
little rushed or just a little like okay
this is alright but let's get back to
the fun and I think maybe some of the
the cutting might have contributed to
that but overall what did it made much
for more sense for the story if instead
of doing scourge even though he was
performed very well I like Karl Urban
wouldn't make more sense if it was
lowkey because it would have finally
been a Redemption arc instead of him
just being a jerk on Sakaki less of a
murder more of a jerk and but like in
this he would have to see how bad hella
is and like how like look he would be
Hellas right-hand man
yeah and it would be forced to because
he can't she would overpower him but he
would also be really like drawn to that
power that would have been obviously
like a big carrot for him yeah I think
with the carrot scourge they were a
scourge I'm sorry but you enemies the
Elliot song which is like scratch
did you hurt every time I hear scared oh
no
we see Elliot anyway hey we should we
want to see ya and imagine that in your
heads because we're not gonna play it
we're gonna get flagged if we do that
well think about it here dance to it
just think about it
and I'm just gonna like rock like this
as I do it parties when like music's
played but yeah and maybe with like
skirts they were just following that
eolr brew Redemption a double machine
gun shot from the comics whereas they're
trying to keep low-key for like his evil
turn and infinity war would be mine
again Loki Loki betrayed us okay well
finally the delete scenes include a one
short amazing cameo by yondu Michael
Rooker from guardians of the galaxy it
was a moment scourge of skirt is about
to execute an innocent Asgardian whim
woman and then the on do steps out of
the crowd and says stop and then he said
instead of sleeping the woman he just
wanted to know where where the offices
of Kevin and Lou are referring to Kevin
studio to Marvel studio co-presidents
Kevin Feige and Louie despedido and then
when he's point in the right direction
he just walks off and looking skirts to
hook Oh about his business killing this
woman it's pretty great right really
where it's breaking it's kind of a jokey
thing yeah he died at the end of
guardians the galaxy vol 2 and clearly
that took place years before Thor ordem
had this as like a joke and they're like
wait he's dead or maybe they shot it
before they knit well maybe like it and
I already heard the angry nerds right
they're like oh it's not gonna work cuz
I mean if you think about it's just like
almost like Bugs Bunny walking into
frame and making a joke
but as we know a Bugs Bunny died at the
end of Marta purfles card Viking funeral
and everything
you can't some of those acne products or
deadly copy it posted again yeah I was
gonna make a Elmer Fudd second-amendment
joke but now is not the time for
okay well let us know what you think
about these deleted scenes in the
comments below what you've prefered
Odin's death in the previous way or
could you have used even more Goldblum
yeah right the answer is yeah we could
always use more of them always oh yeah
and as a reminder to follow us on
Twitter and subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdowns of all your favorite
Marvel movies thanks everybody
all right well moving on to our next
topic the upcoming Deadpool spin-off
x-force and the recent and the recent
trailer for Deadpool 2 the team up movie
between Deadpool and cable there's a
very missable shot showing Deadpool in
Domino's easy beats character joining
three other mysterious figures in the
back of a helicopter these include a
character played by Terry Crews and two
other unknowns these are probably the
members of the x-force and the apparent
future of the Deadpool cable branch of
this cinematic universe that sprawls
everything now the x-force is an
offshoot from the x-men comics it's
headed up by cable and it's never being
way more aggressive and militant and its
tactics it's a way cooler it translates
to it they're awesome yeah Suicide Squad
was trying to be yeah arguably yes now
we've learned we just learned this week
that production for this movie will
begin in October now it's gonna be
directed by Drew Goddard he's a writer
for Deadpool 2 but he's also known for
scripts for the Martian cabin in the
woods Cloverfield he wrote episodes of
lost and Buffy the Vampire Slayer he's
like one of the best writers he's in
some ways another version of Joss Whedon
which is interesting because Joss Whedon
Marvel brought in to launch the Avengers
and become became the golden child for
them and it seems like this side of the
cinematic universe might be trying to do
the same with Drew Goddard but the
official synopsis of x-force goes as
follows the x-men spin-off film that
revolves around Deadpool and cable
leading a blackops force of
down-and-dirty mutant warriors who are
far more ruthless than their x-men
counterparts oh yeah to me this sounds
like a the classic superhero team-up
strategy but with one key difference a
hard-r rating right like assuming
x-force will continue the profanity and
violence sexual humor of the first
Deadpool did and what the second appears
to be doing this might give fans a truly
edgy and funny and awesome alternative
to pasts team-ups like the x-men the
Avengers
Justice League and Suicide Squad but
what do you guys think I know it's a
little early we haven't seen any
anything from this but do you guys think
x-force has the potential to be bigger
than the Avengers was Avengers I would
say like is this a really good pivot for
the x-men franchise what I want to see
more than ever I'm a simple girl when it
comes to x-men all I want to see is the
90s cartoon intro remake where you've
got two sides running at each other and
I want to be x-force and I wanted to be
whoever you want from x-men and I wanted
to just be like like they could do that
they could yeah you don't know it could
be and this one could be in Deadpool 2
yeah I think maybe Avengers is kind of
the high-water mark right because there
was a worldwide phenomenon those things
are super popular they change the game
in so many ways but I think with the R
rating that allows them to explore
things that they never could have I mean
Deadpool was hugely popular and I think
making a hard-r superhero movie allows
him to do things for fans that maybe a
lot of us have been wanting also you
saying X gonna give it to you right this
second because X for x-men and I'm like
a course and it was a double-layered
actually because the X gonna give it to
you was the Deadpool yeah song right it
was it was kind of I mean in the trailer
they use that song so that's why he's in
the trailer in the using that moment
when like Deadpool walked up with
negasonic and Colossus and kind of like
I'm kind of an x-men man they are
they're very cool like the X on the
Terry Cruz's outfit as well so a little
hint to that we just real zoom in we
have the capacity to zoom in because
just stick your face close to the screen
here just say put your face closer he's
packin some pattern in the front door
trooper piece stone I mean Terry Crews
they're not even comparable this guy at
the back like that he has some padding
sports padding I'm guessing cuz I can't
stop looking yeah if I mean if you know
I can't stuff up there look at all his
hair is it's like a wrestler what kind
of sport requires that he's on the
outside of that thing though the girl
back over there that's a girl probably
well in our Deadpool 2 trailer breakdown
actually went to a couple different
theories of who these people are so you
go what yeah I'm saying it's
sport-related cuz he's got knee pads as
well I think they all have the oh
they're all wearing like parachutes you
know and of course you got a strap you
got to get support down there because
why I don't know I'm never gonna skydive
don't worry guys I feel like it's gonna
cut to like both of us just skydiving
like want to mention they do garters
behind the first half of daredevil
season one and that's one of the
best-looking Marvel shows they've ever
done it's pretty like it's really good
in that first half then it gets a little
messy but like it's a it's a great look
for it also he directed cabin in the
woods I think him and just we developed
it but he directed it yeah so he's
already gotten a plus in my book so I'm
I'm excited to see what he does he's got
dark humor he's got violence like he's
got uh if you want like a little bit of
jump scare just to kind of add something
how much of this not like scary but more
like if you just want to like build the
tension and this like he could do a
really good job with that that's cool
yeah I'm really excited to see what
happens it'll be something to really
look forward to in 2019 2020 whenever
this comes I mean we're waiting for God
it's a play it's really boring but it's
a for interpretation it's great yeah
yeah whatever
yeah Magneto and Professor X data did a
play version of it in New York and it's
it was really good yeah they did yeah it
was in London too
anyway well now it's time to move on to
our new rockstars news lightning round
good where did this come from
my places guys do dis questions I'm
gonna fire them up my co-hosts here they
have to answer them as quickly and
without hesitation as possible are you
guys ready choo-choo-choo okay for Sam
let start with you Sam Marvel TV shows
or DC TV shows so I guess the agents of
shield show you know it's easy fighting
a DC winds all really there's a great
question
yeah way to pick a hard one for him okay
for mod what is this is from at dks
films what is your favorite example of
robot /ai uprisings in movies or TV
shows sorry where they went to the
future and Bishop was there how to take
[Applause]
would be best friends cable in Bishop
yeah he could touch how and bring a
Laura from the Logan stuff yeah yep yep
okay and for me at fate Oh shade says
existential crisis of faith really just
a manifestation of our narcissistic need
to grasp concepts that science cannot
yet explain hmm well I would say it
might be part of human instinct to have
something to believe in and isn't
necessarily a lack of science that
creates a need for faith maybe it's
someplace deeper where it comes from
don't try to science out my panic
attacks alright I think when the big
stuff I get scared well thank you three
for everyone who tweeted us to your
questions they're all really good we
only have time for some of them because
lightning but um yeah continued looking
out for our lightning around tweet next
week and and tweet us your questions and
we'll try to get them on the air great
yeah awesome here we go you always
retweeted as well guys let's be honest
we should get one of those Simpson's you
know when like in the very first episode
where they like shot
each other shock collars yeah Devin gets
a control oh boy
next up let's take a look at what we got
in the pipeline for videos coming out on
this channel in the next week yeah it's
gonna be a big week we got more on black
panther we can't get enough talking
about this movie there this the original
cut of rank Googlers movie was three
hours long it sounds like so there are
gonna be a lot of great deleted scenes
we got the inside scoop on what a lot of
those scenes are so keep a lookout for a
video on that Sam's continues MC
rewatched series what happened to other
Marvel Way in the movie no just a
sentence I just could feel the hate
coming in since I if most people hate
that movie but it's actually pretty good
wait I think it's equivalent of like
slowly backing out pretty good just
check out the video when it comes out
yeah yeah yeah Iron Man 3 it's great but
I kind of tried to end a shoehorn an
ending where it's like Iron Man will
never cut back except for a - every
movie after that yeah even movies that
have other heroes in the title ok also a
Walking Dead comes back next week but
for all of you who still exist to like
this show hey we're gonna be doing
videos on it I there's still a lot to
talk about with this show it's still
based on a comic that's good let's see
if they can get back to what was great
about the comic and trying to bring that
into the show rather than having negan
and Rick prematurely fight throw each
other out of a window and then run away
for some reason twice - boy oh boy like
I want to be a zombie they're gonna want
to DVR this episode and watch it alone
rather than with their parents
that's new sad new comment coming out
well now comes in time guys for our
15-second shout outs where each of us
has 15 seconds to shut up plug ramble
without anything we want Sam why don't
you start I'm gonna do Iron Man 3 cuz I
your after watching this week and I was
taking notes through it and then I
stopped because I actually wanted to
watch this a very enjoyable movie
there's a bunch of fun references and
it's a great Tony Stark centric Iron Man
movie which is crazy that they're able
to do that
my shout out will be for the movie
annihilation that comes out this weekend
try to go find it Alex Gansa directed
it's think I did ex machina amazing
sci-fi the studio's thought it was too
complicated for general audiences prove
them wrong go watch this movie how to
make a lot of money I've got too much to
say I've seen annihilation I read the
book don't read the book before you see
the movie but my shout out is to geek
bomb at my channel cuz I've been doing
so many interviews with the cast of
Black Panther and my shot is to Ryan
Coogler I did POW with him what are you
playing watching greeting and he's
playing stardew valley blue 15 on the
data yeah so check all these things out
and finally let's return to the trivia
question with the annihilation coast and
I spoke to Natalie Portman and I told
her that I loved her and six seconds
will be deducted fingers mix that's it
that's cool right cuz he's my favorite
person in the whole world he did a
really good playing watching reading you
can see him just turn into a gate and
that's what gate mom's all about using
econ you know you pointed out that a can
loggers costume looks like that Dragon
Ball Z character I should not oh but
doing the memes is like everything looks
just like don't hate me I don't know all
the Dragon Ball Z characters all right
it looks like it though yeah okay well
just to remind you the question in a
black panther according to the
coordinates visible and his father's
diary and kill mongers flashback what in
real world African country is a nation
of what kind of contained within let's
see what we answered you wrote a city in
Los Angeles death alright well Sam
Zimbabwe is an African country yes bud
please don't humiliate me come on
I thought you wrote Tarzana down but as
Tanzania Tanzania why because they have
a really cool flag Wow black green blue
a little bit of gold that were you
making any country in the entire world
you can do it there was at the project
and Eric you know what um your
handwriting sucks bowls so I'm actually
going to say it how it looks which is
you Gorda you Gorda that's the country
dancer is the Democratic Republic of
Congo
anybody got a map up oh we really do not
me is the country anyway who is it
between yeah yeah did I lose tent city
is a country and you can't miss the
country all right well so confuse then I
don't wait to tell all my family that I
wanted to yog Rafi still have like the
diorama you made of the country and
they're like here I'll gonna ship it to
you is that amazing grade five
Australian education is really doing you
do need some favors now well the winner
mod will get to do her goodbyes can make
fun of our names and then you'll also
get to set up the headline for for Sam
to have to deliver a clever riff
the end is everyone ready I think I got
extra points for saying you get it
anytime you don't play on words it's
fine by me take it away in other news
just we didn't announce that he's I
heard sleeping a red sleeping with but
it's stepping down as the director of
the upcoming Batgirl movie saying that
he didn't really have the real story
idea for it Buffy you laughed at it so
go on we go to number two all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's upcoming Orlando Park Star Wars
Galaxies edge designed to look like a
spacecraft with every window looking out
to space Iraq yeah you'd have be cheaper
to go to space in to get a ticket of
that hotel you're like well reporters
like starts out small and then everybody
gathers and gathers and makes a big
thing it was my favorite thing an early
test screening the DC's Aquaman had
positive reactions from attendees it
made a big splash with the fans
James won my heart with that one hmm he
seems like a great guy he's a dude he's
Australian the upcoming Jerrica origin
movie directed by Todd Phillips is set
to begin shooting in May with Joaquin
Phoenix now in talks to play their Joker
we all know we want Tommy Wiseau cuz he
want
oh hi Bruce are you wanna I want him to
tithe he tweeted Todd DM me and I wanted
him to say oh hi Todd there's no joke
there 9 director JJ Abrams said that he
wouldn't allow for
criticisms of the last Jedi to influence
the story for the next movie and we also
learned that JJ sometimes lies in press
conferences yeah that's very true
well well done to both of you Maude you
really know how to set up a count as a
joke yeah you know it's not a joke
people just laughed at it all right well
ma do you want to take uh yeah fantastic
but hey I want to thank Sam Buffy basha
who's at Sam Basha we've also got Erik
Voss II avis is in the name say
something say a word a word oh that
wasn't a word though that's what I'm
Maude Garrett
that's Maude Garrett to us to tease yeah
well comment down below and tweet us at
new rock stars like this video share it
around and subscribing to archives for
deep dives and to all the stuff you love
see you next week
Buffy